Where were you on the night of July 27th HMM?
HMMMMM turns out the very act of remembering
might make you forget.
And that’s not a bad thing.
Hey guys, Julia here for DNews
Scientists have known for a while that humans
have terrible memories.
Memories can change over time and we can even
remember things that never happened.
We’ve talked about this a bunch on the show,
check out some links in the description for
those episodes.
We know memory sucks, but science hasn’t
been sure why we forget things at all.
Is it a passive thing that just happens?
Well it turns out forgetting is a pretty active
process.
Your brain does it on purpose and in a couple
of different ways.
New research published in the journal Nature
Neuroscience found that by actively recalling
an event, related memories might be forgotten.
The researchers asked participants to look
at images and to recall them several times.
MRI scans reveled that as the participants
remembered the images, competing memories
initially fired up too, but then became suppressed.
And that might be a good thing.
That way, when I for example, talk about fine
China for a dinner party, you don’t immediately
think of the country.
The researchers think maybe these new findings
could “be incredibly useful when trying
to overcome a negative memory from our past”.
So forgetting might be a good thing, it actually
might make us remember other memories.
But how does that happen?
What’s going on in the brain?
Another study published in the journal Cell,
found a specific protein that might be responsible
for forgetting.
The so-called musashi protein helps build
connections between neurons called synapses,
where information is passed between them.
The researchers genetically modified ringworms
to not produce this protein.
Both regular and modified ringworms seem to
learn the same, but over time, the musashi-less
worms remembered better.
The researchers think the protein aids in
forgetting by stopping the stabilization of
synaptic connections.
Basically when you learn something new, new
connections are made between neurons.
Some proteins make these connections strong
and more stable, but this musashi protein
actively disrupts this process, making the
ringworms, and maybe other animals, forgetful.
The researchers think this might help the
nervous system retains its plasticity and
that if it didn’t you could develop serious
mental disorders.
Another study published in the journal Neuron
found that right as we form a memory we are
also forgetting it.
The study looked at brains in fruit flies
to see how it works.
They found that dopamine helps form a memory
and helps us forget it.
Dopamine is a neurotransmitter that does a
lot of things in the brain, especially with
reward, pleasure and learning.
The researchers found that as dopamine is
released in the brain it first acts on one
receptor called dDA1 which helps memories
form.
After a memory solidifies, dopamine is still
being released but this time it acts on another
receptor called DAMB which starts to chip
away at the memory unless something significant
is attached to it, in the case of the flies,
that might be a sweet smell or an electric
shock.
The process of solidifying a memory from a
short term to long term is called consolidation.
The researchers think this mechanism might
be why savants have such extraordinary memories.
Maybe it’s not that they have a better memory
but that they worse forgetting mechanisms.
And that could be beneficial!
It might help us remember the more important
things and keep us from being overwhelmed
by the bad things and the not so important
things, like certain exes.
Anyways, before we go on a trip down memory
lane, do you love DNews?
We want to hear from you!
We’ve got a quick survey, it’ll take just
two minutes.
It’s the first link in the description.
We wanna know what you think about our show!
It would really help us out, we want to make
the best show we possible can.
As always thanks for watching!
So do you have any memories you’d rather
forget?
Let us know in the comments below and while
you’re at it don’t forget to hit those
like and subscribe buttons and keep coming
back here!
We’ve got new episodes every day of the
week.